bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo où nous allons
reparler des animaux fantastiques 3 les
secrets de dumbledore ça fait un moment
qu'on n'est pas revenu sur le sujet et
là avec cette deuxième bande-annonce
j'estime qu'il peut être pourquoi pas
intéressant de faire une petite mise au
point concernant le film ce dernier
arrive à très grands pas le 13 avril
donc voilà on n'est pas si loin que ça
de la sortie déjà ce film a une
particularité c'est que l'on ne sait
toujours pas si ce troisième volet sera
le dernier de la saga ou si warner
prévoit toujours de faire cinq films
vous le savez tous la saga des animaux
fantastiques a eu pas mal de
complications dont notamment le
changement d'acteur pour grindelwald
avec johnny depp et match amical scène
on ne va pas trop s'étendre là dessus
sur les complications etc mais du coup
bah on nous parlait de cinq films à puis
après deux trois puis on est revenu à 5
etc bref on ne sait pas vraiment et au
final il est fort à parier que warner
attend de voir les résultats des animaux
fantastiques 3 pour savoir s'ils feront
la suite etc mais en même temps dans
tous les cas ce troisième opus ne pourra
jamais être véritablement la fin tout
simplement car en termes de cohérence
nous savons que de mulder et grindelwald
se sont véritablement affrontés dans un
combat ultime en 45 et les animaux
fantastiques 2 s'est déroulée en 1927
donc voilà impossible qu'il y ait une
différence de 20 années entre les deux
films le synopsis du troisième film nous
parle plutôt des années 1930 soit
quelques années plus tard ce qui est
largement plus cohérent et cela reste
quand même loin du combat entre
dumbledore et grindelwald ensuite
rentrons plus en détail dans la
thématique que nous donne le titre du
film soit les secrets de dumbledore
c'est quelque chose dont on parle depuis
le premier film mais la saga des animaux
fantastiques même si nous suivons les
aventures de norbert dragon's hausse est
avant tout une saga qui traite de
l'opposition d'albus dumbledore et de
gaylord grindelwald et les
bandes-annonces du troisième film
insiste pas mal sur cette thématique
nous retrouvons des plans d'albus
dumbledore vieux notamment devant la
pensine histoire d'accentuer l'idée que
dumbledore possède un lourd passé et a
fait des choix et des actions qui ont
fait qu'il est devenu l'un des plus
grands sorciers que le monde n'ait
jamais connue sauf que se passer on sait
notamment via les livres et les films et
bien il n'a pas toujours été tout rose
albus était le plus grand allié de
grindelwald
il était en quête de puissance notamment
avec la recherche des reliques de la
mort il voulait changer le monde et pour
arriver à ses fins il a dû faire des
sacrifices et c'est totalement la dent
que l'on va plonger dans ce troisième
opus le passé de dumbledore et notamment
sa relation avec grindelwald pour moi il
y aura dans le film quatre points
principaux concernant le passé d'albus
dumbledore qui vont ressurgir le premier
sera ce fameux pacte de sang qui relie
albus et gay laërt et qui les empêchent
de s'affronter directement même si nous
savons dans le fond ce que c'est le
deuxième film introduisait avant tout le
concept de ce pacte maintenant on va
très certainement à voir l'historique et
le contexte de pourquoi et comment ils
l'ont fait et surtout savoir s'il peut
être détruit moi je vous avoue
personnellement j'aimais toujours un
doute quant à sa possible destruction il
est vrai que normalement le point
central et final de la saga sera
l'affrontement entre dun bol d'or et
grindelwald se concluant sur la victoire
d'al bus néanmoins par le biais de la
saga harry potter nous savons que gay
laërt est toujours en vie il n'a pas été
tué il a été enfermé dans sa propre
prison à norman garde depuis 1945
jusqu'au jour où voldemort lui rendra
visite
d'ailleurs concernant la baguette de
sureau le film du prince de sang-mêlé
nous l'avait prouvé il ne suffit pas de
tuer son adversaire pour qu'elles
obéissent à son nouveau possesseur il
suffit simplement de désarmer son
opposant donc voilà après cela reste une
idée comme ça ensuite pour moi toujours
concernant le passé d'albus la plus
grosse partie sera amenée par abel forte
la présence du frère de dumbledore dans
ce troisième film n'est pas anodine nous
sommes sur un film dédié aux secrets de
dumbledore alors si à belfort tu es là
c'est pour une raison bien précise à
mener la problématique d'ariana la
petite soeur d'albus et abel forte
ariana est décédé lors d'un affrontement
entre grindelwald abel forte et albus et
c'est le point de rupture ultime entre
les deux frères à belfort tu as toujours
tenues albus responsable de la mort de
leur soeur notamment à cause de sa
liaison avec grindelwald et son
obsession pour le pouvoir et le truc
c'est qu'il ya énormément de non-dits
concernant ce grand conflit déjà on n'a
jamais réellement su qui avait tué
ariane à ce jour là peut-être que
c'était albus peut-être que c'était
grindelwald on ne sait pas et peut être
qu'enfin on aura la lumière sur cette
affaire ensuite vous connaissez tous
cette théorie qui est devenu un peu réel
dans l'imaginaire collectif c'est le
fait car rihanna était en fait un obscur
yal développant est un obscur us pour
rappel dans l'histoire de la famille des
dom bol d'or à rihanna va connaître un
tragique accident à l'âge de 6 ans car
elle se fera sévèrement attaquées par
des moldus qui l'ont vu pratiquer de la
magie perceval dumbledore le père
d'ariana albus et abel forte en colère
contre les moldus se vengera et
attaquera ces derniers sauf que cette
action le conduira à ascq avant
l'accident plus l'emprisonnement de son
père va créer chez ariane à un sévère
traumatisme qui la fera rejeté ses
pouvoirs magiques et c'est à l'âge de 14
ans que dans une énorme crise de fureur
et de colère qu'arianna durera sans
faire exprès sa mère kendra dumbledore à
belfort et albus seront donc les
derniers parents d'ariane à sauf calbuth
évidemment est toujours absent et dévoué
à grindelwald ses études et sa quête de
puissance a rien à koch toutes les cases
de l'obscur russe et c'est justement ce
secret ce non-dit sur la famille
dumbledore qui pourrait expliquer
pourquoi grindelwald était en quête de
retrouver croyance qui est un obscur yal
développant un obscur us et de l'autre
côté cela expliquerait pourquoi albus à
engager norbert ragonneau qui est un
mage iso logist qui a déjà réussi à
capturer un obscur us et à l'enfermer
dans sa valise norbert serai là pour
justement sauver croyances et par
conséquent enlevé à grindelwald sont
plus puissants serviteur d'ailleurs il
faudra répondre aussi à la déclaration
de grindelwald affirmant que croyance
serait aurelius dumbledore mais rien ne
permet d'affirmer encore s'il a menti ou
non on avait déjà exploré cette question
à l'époque mais il ya de fortes chances
vu que croyance et albus vont
s'affronter que nous aurons les réponses
dans ce film enfin concernant les
secrets de dumbledore il est clair que
nous allons avoir un début de l'ordre du
phénix normalement le groupe secret a
été fondée en 1970 par albus dumbledore
pour contrer voldemort et les mangemorts
sauf que le second film des animaux
fantastiques nous l'a prouvé par le
biais de nicolas flamel et de son livre
orné d'un phénix il existe déjà à cette
époque une équipe secrète dont albus
fait partie nous retrouvons notamment
eulalie x une professeur de l'école de
sorcellerie il vers morny situés en
amérique du nord et qui sera beaucoup
plus présente dans ce troisième opus
nous avons aussi liu tao un nouveau
personnage qui apparaîtra dans le film
et qui lui aussi fait partie de cette
équipe puisque nous retrouvons son nom
dans le livre de nicolas flamel bhutta
haut va d'ailleurs me permettre de faire
la transition puisque outre les secrets
de dumbledore le film semble avoir une
très grosse partie dédiée à la politique
effectivement en plus d'être un membre
de l'équipe secrète dumbledore yotaro
est également candidat à l'élection au
poste de mogwai pts suprême de la
confédération internationale des
sorciers nous le remarquons par le biais
des banderoles où il est écrit en
chinois traditionnel qu'il faut voter
pour lui mais il n'est pas le seul et
cette élection va permettre
l'intégration de nouveaux personnages
notamment la brésilienne vie chez sia
santos ou pareil nous retrouvons des
banderole à son effigie avec son nom
indiquant qu'il faut voter pour elle
également nous aurons l'intégration du
personnage downtown vos gueules un
sorcier allemand qui est l'actuel moguai
mme suprême ce qui est intéressant avec
cette élection c'est que déjà la
confédération internationale des
sorciers avec le titre de mof guen
suprême et bien c'est un peu on va dire
le pouvoir ultime dans le monde des
sorciers car évidemment le mot gones
suprême est quelqu'un qui possède
beaucoup de pouvoir et d'influencé dans
le monde des sorciers c'est quelqu'un
qui a les yeux un peu partout qui garde
un oeil sur tout qui peut donner l'ordre
d'intervenir dans des conflits etc etc
grindelwald et forcément intéressés par
cette élection dans le second film ils
organisaient déjà des rencontres avec
ses partisans notamment en france et
dans les bandes-annonces nous le voyons
faire un discours aux côtés des autres
candidats nous le voyons même se faire
aduler par ses partisans et il y à même
à court plan où nous le voyons au côté
du mot gones suprême actuelle
anton voghell il est clair pour moi que
green day valdes souhaiteraient se faire
élire c'est l'accès aux pleins pouvoirs
c'est le moyen d'amener la guerre contre
les moldus en réunissant de plus en plus
de partisans est évidemment c'est un
excellent moyen pour lui d'avoir les
yeux rivés sur albus dumbledore et
l'isoler seul contre tous sans avoir à
l'affronter directement donc voilà il
semblerait qu'il y ait deux thématiques
principales dans ce film une partie
dédiée au passé et au secret d'albus
dumbledore et par conséquent greendale
valdes mais également une partie plus
actuelles dédié à la montée en puissance
de google earth dans le monde des
sorciers avec cette élection et toute la
thématique politique internationale
je pense que nous allons nous arrêter là
pour le moment alors il est vrai je n'ai
pas parlé de l'absence totale de tina
golstein dans les thrillers c'est
pourtant un personnage principal de la
saga personnellement je pense que c'est
souhaité tina aura certainement un rôle
clé dans ce troisième film et en tant qu
aurore bas elle pourrait être pourquoi
pas en infiltration ou quelque chose du
genre et puis voilà ça surcoût ni a
rejoint green bellwald donc c'est sûr
qu'elle ne va pas en rester là mais bon
il n'y a aucune information pour le
moment écoutez c'était une petite vidéo
dédiée aux animaux fantastiques trois
j'espère que cela vous aura plu si c'est
le cas évidemment n'hésitez pas à
laisser un petit pouce bleu un
commentaire sur si le film vous hype ou
pas et puis bah écoute et que le 'lion'
rares soit avec vous cet argot rock
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]